le 31 janvier à minuit la
grande-bretagne et quitte l'union
européenne va débuter maintenant une
période de 11 mois jusqu'au 31 décembre
pendant laquelle nous allons réfléchir
ensemble à la relation future cet accord
je lis est important puisque hâtives sur
trois grands principes l'absence de
droit d'antoine les quotas mais aussi
l'absence de joplin
cette absence de d'un ping est
d'importance aussi en matière sociale
c'est le point sur lequel
personnellement je vais être vigilante
en commission emploi pas de concurrence
déloyale aussi en matière sociale et
garantir des normes sociales élevées
telles qu'elles ont été élaborées par
l'europe sinon à nos portes nous aurons
un vrai risque de dumping social et de
mobilité qui se ferait surtout en
bretagne avec des normes sociales mois
et demi au sein de la commission du
commerce international
nous allons définir la future relation
entre l'union européenne et le royaume
uni c'est une situation complètement
inédites parce que quand nous cherchons
à mettre en place des accords de
libre-échange d'habitude c'est pour
rapprocher nos normes réglementaires
ici il va choisir de construire une
relation avec un état qui quitte l'union
européenne et qui quittent le marché
intérieur sur une question comme la
défense par exemple le royaume uni a
toujours été opposé à
l'approfondissement de la défense
européenne commune
on voit maintenant que les britanniques
qui en sortent
insiste pour y rester dans tous les
domaines ça va changer des choses et
notamment dans les domaines de
l'éducation et la culture
quand on parle d éducation européenne
on pense bien sûr à erasmus plus la
question est de savoir c'est les
citoyens britanniques vont rester dans
ou en dehors du programme ou s'ils
voient dans un pays tiers et dans ce cas
forcément il y aura une distance qui va
se créer puisqu'ils participeront de
manière beaucoup moins proche au
programme et la france qui est le
premier pays à envoyer des étudiants et
des jeunes en formation et des
enseignants au royaume uni sera un des
premiers pays pénalisés ce qui concerne
l'espace le rêve du royaume uni a déjà
investi beaucoup dans nos programmes
comme copernicus ou google vidéo que
plus d'un milliard d'euros mais en
sortant de l'union européenne ils ne
pourront plus participer à tous qui sera
liée à leur sécurité
la sortie des britanniques de l'union
européenne pose beaucoup de questions en
matière d'enjeux maritime et pas
uniquement sur la question de la pêche
qui va être un sujet majeur dans les
prochains mois mais aussi parce que
l'océan et est global et qu'il va
falloir ensemble malgré tout continuer à
répondre à plus de connaissance de
l'océan plus de préservation d économie
maritime plus durable et enfin une
gouvernance mondiale de l'océan
il va falloir continuer à travailler
ensemble